i am so excited to meet our next guest
she is the director of the critically
acclaimed and award-winning projects
like selma when they see us a wrinkle in
time she is one of the most prolific
filmmakers out there i just watched
colin in black and white with complete
marvel in my eyes not only did she make
last month's forbes world's most
powerful women
but she's also behind a groundbreaking
new cw series called naomi about a
teenage girl who discovers that she's a
superhero not only do i want to see
everything through ava duvernay's lens
but i can't wait to see what this series
is all about oh please and welcome the
one the only eva dubernay
oh my gosh i wanted to talk to you for
so long
i am a long time admirer and i'm so so
pleased to meet you i can't wait for it
to be in person one day oh my goodness i
would totally koala
bear to your eucalyptus tree
let's do it one day i look forward okay
so you have just been this incredibly
prolific storyteller but you weren't
always a director
you had other jobs before you pr
waitressing scooping frozen yogurt
like what did you like and embrace or
want to get away from before you became
the huge director that you are today
well you know the beautiful thing is i
loved all my jobs i really really did
and i think each one you know prepared
me for the next job i was a damn good
waitress and i just feel like if i ever
need to pick up a few extra dollars or
if hey this directing thing doesn't work
out that would probably be you can find
me in a small town diner and i i was
good drew i was a good waitress because
i like to make sure that people were
happy that they had what they needed you
know that they were able to just dine
and kick back and so i can always
waitress if i need to okay this explains
everything that i believed that i
thought i knew
about you that that that nurturing
really does come through and it is a
choice it's an approach and you know
someone you started out you know this
particular part of your journey oprah if
she isn't the person who sort of
nurtured guide us guided us and mentored
us all
towards the brilliant of the aha moment
and i wanted to ask you something about
oprah's advice because i think it
applies so much to the modern world
today
she spoke to you something about a
critique or a review that you got for a
project you were working on and she
walked you through it the reason i
wanted to ask you was because i feel
like this applies so much to people on
social media and comments can you tell
me about that
yeah it was it was a review that i got
for one of my early films that was kind
of particularly nasty like you know not
someone critiquing the craft but kind of
um you know being a little mean for no
reason and it hurt my feelings and i was
talking with her about it and i'm
i'm blubbering on and on and on and i'm
one minute five and minute ten about how
it makes me feel at the end it was very
quiet she said
do you know this person
and i said well no she said do they know
you personally and i was like no she
said so why does it matter
and
i thought wow i don't even know this
person like i didn't even know what the
person looked like i just had read the
words and they heard and so it's really
kind of bifurcating and separating words
from feeling from people
and really the whole thing gets down to
what do you value do i value these words
from like a ghost on a page who i don't
know
or do i value my experience making that
thing how much i loved it all the love
that i put into it and the people who
were receiving it in the way that i
intended which was a lot of people but
you know you always focus on the
negative thing you could be in a room
with everyone smiling and most people
are looking at the one person who
doesn't like you know the the spinach
dip like why don't they like it everyone
else likes
just human nature exactly it's never
gonna work
you gotta work to dismantle it within
yourself that is such rich brilliant
advice and we can all use it because
it's true and we can apply it to social
media and we are seeing people be
affected by comments that person hurt
your feelings we are human beings so if
you can separate yes i am a human and
this makes me feel a certain way but to
take the oprah advice of do you know
this person that they know you and start
to untangle yourself from the web of
pain
is just so brilliant and we all need
that in this world so thank you read it
thank you now is it true that you've
been stuck in an elevator not once not
twice but three times with three
different legends
i get stuck in elevators with like icons
it's like my thing i don't even know
what happens but
it literally if i'm in the elevator with
someone who's a known person i'm like oh
this elevator is going to stop it's
happened to me three different times and
will you tell me what hail
my favorite one well two of them were
mean and one of them was really nice so
i'll tell you the nice one
so i was stuck in an elevator i was a
publicist and i was working on a movie
and uh
he looks at me and i say
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm doing the
buzzer i'm trying to get down he's like
you know it'll start again when it's
time i said okay
look at each other so tell me about
yourself let's talk
and we end up talking it's tom cruise
okay and it was so so lovely and so for
maybe five years after that i got
flowers on my birthday every uh every
birthday from tom cruise and he with a
little note about hey how you doing oh
my god i love him so much
now i love him more thank you for being
a fly on the wall in that amazing
elevator last question is it true that
you got in an accident as a fender
bender when you were a teen because of a
cute guy
yes i really like that i really like
this boy
um and so i had my first car and i was
driving uh by his house as one does
and i guess i got lost in him watering
the grass or something because literally
i smashed straight into a parked car
and um
cut to this he ends up being my
boyfriend for quite a while
it started with you know offender you
never know how how relationships begin
i love this story
[Music]